Hey! What's up guys?
BuzzFeed family-friendly Felix here! Today we have...
something special, something unique.
Drunk glasses. Hilarious.
It's glasses that make
you, get this, less ugly. God damnit.
Drunk ... They make ... They make you drunk.
Do my eyes look cool in this?
This is what happens when you fall into a vat...
of Everclear.
Oh, I've never been this drunk at work.
The second you move your head, you have to, like, reestablish where you are.
You really see how ....
So apparently these...
glasses are made for actual testing of
drunk driving and stuff like that.
They're legit glasses. Let's see what
crazy stuff BuzzFeed did to check out
these glasses.
We're going to do a variety of activities here at the office, and we're going to see
how our motor skills compare from when we're drunk versus when we're sober.
Fuck. That was my idea with the video.
God damn it, Buzzfeed.
All right. So they eat food.
Shoveling something in my mouth. Got it.
Putting the keys in the door, to me, was the hardest part.
Come on!
Got to take a piss!
Got to take a piss.
They also walked the line!
Fake.
It's fake.
All right. These are glasses. They take away your vision ...
but alcohol messes with your sense
of balance. That's in your ear not your
eyes. Learn grammar Buzz-feed. Learn
what you're talkin' about.
I wasn't fooling anyone.
Like, I might have walked the line, but the cop have been like, "Just get in the car."
Well, clearly you're bad at faking drunk driving BuzzFeed.
DISAPPOINTED! All right. So I have the
glasses myself. I thought I'd check it
out. See if I can spoof them. I can show
their theory to be wrong.
The confidence you get from being inebriated, you really see how crazy it is to try to ...
I like how they try and end it with, like, a nice message.
Like the upbeat music.
If I ever caught my kids getting this drunk,  they'd be dead.
And they're one and three.
I'm warning you now.
That's right. It was all about drunk driving.
Okay, this is the first time I am ever putting these on. Here we go.
Oh my god. I feel so ... Okay, you know what, maybe
the balance is a bit fucked up. Oh. Oh. Shit.
Man, I feel so short. Am I shorter?
Nope.
Petting Edgar sober, simple.
Edgar. Edgar, my sweet dog.
Come on. Come on. Edgar. Come on.
Okay. Easy.
So fucking weird. Does my eyes look weird?
Do I look sexy?
It doesn't. It looks normal.
It looks pretty normal.
Is this a good thumbnail?
Oh, yeah.
My name is Felix. I'm about to
do a somersault. So hard. This foor. I don't want to do it.
It's really hard. It's really hard. I don't want to do it.
Maybe if I'm drunk I can do it. Okay.
Oh, shit.
Edgar, watch out.
He's fine.
Ah! Ah fucking shit. Hell yeah.
I feel so ... What is the matter with you?
Don't make me hit you.
All right.
We're gonna make some tea.
This should be easy.
Okay.
Just need to look really close. I don't
know how you work this thing.
is it plugged in?
Got electrified. My god.
What is this doing here? How do I ...
This is so hard. I can't see anything
Ah. God damn it. Oh, I did it. I don't know
how I did it but I did it damn it.
What kind of tea would you guys like?
Don't worry about that. Got dark souls mug.
It's so annoying to wear these. We have ...
80 bags of tea . There you go. I got you.
God damn it ! Okay.
Nailed it. Okay. I think it's ready.
Oh god. I'm scared.  This is hot water.
Oh my god. I think I'm gonna ...
Hey, look at that boy.
Okay. Now just .. You guys want some sugar?
How many cups?
I seek three cups. I'm guessing this is
the right one. Ah fuck. Nailed it.
Hey, that's pretty good. Look at that.
Edgar, can you clean this up?
You want some eggs boy?
I got you eggs. God damn. It's really like being drunk.
I understand. Okay. We need a bowl. Okay. How many eggs would you like?
Ow. I hit my hand.
I feel like I'm How To Basic right now.
God damn it.
Oh my god damn.
Fuck. How do I turn it off?
I don't ... I don't know how this thing
works. Okay. Yeah, we're just wasting eggs
at this point. Is that it? Is that all I
have to do?
Eggs. Making eggs while drunk, not a problem.
I'm fucking good at being drunk, man.
What can I say this is clearly way too
easy. I'm too good at being drunk. It's
time to go outside.
Let's see what drunk is really all about.
I forgot about the stairs. Oh shit.
We got stairs. These are deadly stairs.
Which floor are we on?
Driving drunk.
Ow!
Why didn't you move?
Oh Jesus Christ.
Help.
Help me.
Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh.
[Intense Music]
It's not easy being drunk. It's not easy.
Being drunk is cool and all, but what if
you get doubles drunk?
Yeah. That one. Yeah. That's some good shit.
We'll get that one, please. Do you want to try them on?
Hey, you won't be needing this now.
Perfect. Keep the change. Thank you very much. Have
a good one, man. Buh-bye.
Lets go to park and drink this shit.
Oh, how much do I have to drink?
I'm ready! Remember ... Remember kids ...
don't drink and drive.
I'm so scared.
Oh yeah. We're going
slalom baby.
[Car honks]
As you guys know, I'm a really good at
parkour. Top top-quality parkour, man.
But how would it look like if you're drunk?
Oh, what's your fucking problem?
Put them on. Put them on.
Yes! That's why you're ...
Fucking hell.
This is fucked up.
What is this thing?
I'm going to sue him.
See you later, Felix!
Okay guys. Let's just be serious here
for one second. It's really important
that if you're drunk, never ever
go to a skate park because that was fucking
crazy. What happened? The fuck was that?
I almost died. Oh and also and don't drink
and drive or whatever.
BYE